hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the consequence now this
is the second DLC in the evil within DLC
series and there's only been three and I
think there only will be three so I
believe this picks up back with kidman
again but what I don't know
would you like to import the acquired
archive entries sure oh no I didn't
complete the torn letter oh I don't know
if that's gonna really affect anything I
really hope it doesn't because I would
love to get to the end of this I mean I
really do regret that the key you rami
mode or whatever that was where it was
pitch black except for the light like I
wish that would have carried on but it
says chapter 3 illusions all i aiming a
gun from behind do you have passed
secrets haunt you
maybe who's that you wish to tell them
but something holds you back maybe
no thanks no stop get away from me oh
hey how's it going oh I'm awake now in a
hospital bed I'm not back I wouldn't be
torn up if I was actually back those
dolls have sold sighs hi
oh don't be don't be spotlight lady legs
yeah the chapter is named illusions oh I
wonder I'm I'm a-comin
I'm sure this is all real hmm
Who am I uh am I in the place got it
really when she was darker than this
yeah I am I'm in Castellanos dream
Leslie was in this is where Castellanos
would stare at himself for hours on end
dreaming that he was injecting brain
juice into his own brain and then
rambling about something about the dead
wife and his drinking habits hello yeah
this totally is yeah hey you what's
going on where is this place I'm afraid
I cannot answer that Oh
waste of time hello oh I see what's that
there this whole time
I mean Castellanos only had a frickin
hello why are you inviting me back here
I don't have any keys to unlock anything
I doubt that I'm gonna be able to do
anything oh it is open
I thought the giant red light above it
would have been more prohibitory hello
what are you covering
that's the old save music
you seem safe but that seemed no such
safe hi you 60 likes all that sexy legs
oh god you used to say Leslie I knew
that was gonna be bad oh god damn it
okay
people are suffering
alright plenty of Mobius can now do the
same for everyone
is a machine designed to connect
everyone subconsciousness and whomever
is at the center has the power to
influence all of that sounds agree he's
a better tool to change the world to
lead society needs a curator and Mobius
will be just that assuring in the next
death of humanity with you at the head I
imagine oh man illusions was no joke
this is getting trippy right off the bat
and I love it no no oh I didn't notice
the trail of blood I better see kitty I
better see Jojo again
we must have that boy he will enable us
to change everything you're tall I
needn't remind you the consequences for
failure
I need sure there must be some way to
stop him yeah exactly I don't understand
what the threat would be if ruvik
actually left the system I mean I don't
understand the limits with which the
physical realm and the mental realm
collide whoa there's a red light over
there hello what's going on over I mean
I know that I need to go over here I
don't know if there's like a secret or
if that's the way I'm supposed to go oh
no okay I need to shatter and more to
expose it hey lady
can you give me like some inkling stop
listening to me what I have nothing to
say to you apparently goodbye now I
shall carry on my kidman task I know
sure I am you're that guy they gave me
advice just we're all crazy hate Rubik
hate the mans consumed by it he wants
out wants to get his revenge as you know
he wants back what he feels the world
took from him and how does he know about
revenge Rick's dad cousin stepbrother
brother despite our powerful benefactors
with this much collateral damage it's
only a matter of time before people
start to take notice
Casey PD has been dropping by a female
officer CW named Keith regardless the
police are not something I should be
involved with Mobius says they will take
care of it and make an effort to ensure
KCPD leave us alone then there is the
reporter from the Crimson post Ivan
something or other he has become a
personal annoyance he barely qualifies
as a tabloid
Journal and writing cover story but
tales Aslam church sacrifices another
nonsense but now he's being persistent
about the missing patients claim I'll be
damned if he is the man who brings
beacon down it seems that Reuben could
be useful for other forms of problem
solving perhaps I can interest this
reporter in an exclusive interview
illusive that would be exquisite I can't
believe how genius my plans are even
though Reuben is way smarter than I
would ever be
hello so I'm assuming that oh this is
where things get trippy I'm assuming
that rule order okay bye geez Leslie why
you gotta be like that why you still
here and he must be too yeah everyone's
still here I still don't understand like
how does the stem system work how is
everyone plugged into the system because
at the end of the original game we all
woke up in bathtubs hey Castellanos you
want to shed some light on the situation
must he be he doesn't have anything to
do with this you don't know that he had
everything to do with this he solved
everything hello
are you both roof explain well you Bob
move explain oh I get it okay well I'm
not gonna be able to do this but
hopefully I can get like all the
fragments from this area so oh hello
15-5 and to you say those seem like
excellent combinations this is an easy
puzzle can I get back there though can I
could i connect good thank you
and this is just independent well that
was easy that wasn't hard at all oh hi
you're here to reflect my shame
oh it's number one okay I can be on the
extreme look out for these I have to
explore absolutely everywhere or else
I'm going to kick myself in the teeth
and then all of you can yeah this isn't
a safe place
this is castellanos dream hi can I help
you excuse me are you coming on to me
excuse you wow that was weird
okay you look a little pale what am I
gonna find useful by the way uh excuse
me lady
are you a ghost I don't understand what
you want for me what am i doing okay
what am i finding useful what do you
what are you doing I don't don't know
don't know I don't get it okay user the
odds of compatibility are astronomical
but the boy Leslie you're saying he's a
compatible subject yes and based on
Rubens notes the stem should be able to
run with Leslie as its source I need you
to do tests determine what must be done
to make him the blank slate we need okay
and make sense I knew what Leslie was
capable of why Dan why would they hide
that from me that makes so much sense
okay now it's all coming together that
explains why they both wanted why Reuben
wants Leslie but if it won't be any
value if Reuben comes out as Leslie
that's why it's a problem because then
it could be like they could be incognito
and Reuben would be Leslie and then they
plug Leslie back into the system and it
would be exactly the same well excuse me
I wasn't done looking around terminal
here on the lowest floor uh-huh it's
George over there George all George all
hello that looks pretty well what's the
point of that I'm here with me he's
probably headed there and that may be my
way out of here yeah but why is Leslie
headed there
I mean dis Leslie I sense it thing I was
gonna open up
oh no was that where I was supposed to
go I thought I was supposed to go
somewhere else hey let me make sure I've
got absolutely everything because I
don't want to miss out I don't want
everyone to yell at me in the comments
down below I mean no less yelling
admiration and praise then absolutely
feel free to scream it from the
mountaintops but I'm not even kissed is
that drawing up a butt
no that's drawing up a mitochondrial
seed nothing I don't know what I'm
talking about
I didn't think biomedical engineering
it's all a big lie I meant to say viral
something I don't even know I don't know
what it was I can't get through with the
power up get things running again what
do you mean power out this is all in
your mind just think powerful thoughts
hi you left your twin brother behind a
danger generator room
okay now this more like it this is dark
hope rain juice are you gonna give me
something well I can't get anything like
this fine play your game yep
who's hiding from me that's a generator
room all right
is someone gonna pop out of me oh my god
David I knew something that's gonna pop
out of me they're about to get it he'll
kick like no other
Oh my flashlight oh boy
now we're talking oh really
oh really I have to make do with a glow
stick oh yeah I don't know about that
but this is kind of Awesome
oh it's vanish all over again I hear you
so why do these make more glow when
they're on the ground but not so much
when I am need them in hand down there
okay I don't know how long they last for
how many I have maybe I have unlimited I
can just fling him willy-nilly but I'm
not gonna bank on that real quick whoa
don't sprint here trying to be a little
selfie that doesn't go anywhere what the
hell goddammit I was not happy I didn't
even know oh that was the guy that I
threw down I thought he would have been
dead
okay
if I toss movies this all sounds very
bad well that was useless I don't need
to throw another one doing I can lure
him you alive there better not be
back away sonny jim
I'm sorry if I'm not saying a lot that's
really stressful okay all right I got
this okay I did it
checkpoint good good for me I wanted a
ward god those there must be a way to
get the power back on I wouldn't know
about that it seems like I actually do
have an unlimited number of these things
I can just throw them as much as I want
I don't know why I wasn't doing that
already I was just trying to be a little
conservative about it okay
oh man I gotta make sure okay this seems
like exactly the place where they would
have like a hidden away one that I
wouldn't immediately be able to see I'm
talking about the scrap of paper there's
I'm willing to bet let me just double
check I want to backtrack just a little
bit here now that I know that I have
unlimited number of these oh maybe maybe
yeah I don't know if maybe I missed one
already if I missed one already I'm
gonna be so mad with myself because that
seems like exactly the kind of were they
would definitely have put a secret path
to get something or other yeah sorry
about the 50 throw I've been thrown a
lot of these pulling them out of my
unlimited bag of tricks yeah so far so
good well that looks like a pit to death
is that a way to go or is that just bad
I'm gonna guess that's bad all righty
then
I keep expecting at any moment that
spotlight sexy legs to clap out of me
that's a horrible name need a better
name
I hope the comments have developed a
better name for that hi he's doing that
why do I hear don't see I hear
everywhere and do not see I don't like
that how do I hear
oh they're above me okay that makes more
sense okay are they coming this way oh
oh what do i do what do i do what do I
do
they coming this way no no definitely
not
so now okay all right this seems bad why
is that close that looks definitely like
a pit of death it would be really do she
over them to hide a page down there okay
all right this is so slender man I'm
getting spayed scraps I'm collecting
them throughout the mission there's a
Slenderman guy chasing me with grabby
hands and grabby tentacles
that sounds fun is that what the party
is Jimin wants to party it's just a lot
of noises for now I'm really wondering
if I could have just blazed through this
really quickly oh that's good the game
keeps me
that girl bunk did that get you
well considering it's stuck in your body
I'm I'm just under the assumption that
maybe you're still alive here hmm I
wonder I was wondering about that why is
that squeaking in the wind it's not like
there's any window I didn't do that
whoa you are LOI and I do not like it
there dude dear I'm towering like a
little baby you ain't got nobody
okay I don't have anything to throw okay
it was not gone not gone not gone in
here yes please
Thank You Heidi Heidi Heidi Heidi Heidi
Heidi okay it's good it's good
they have no idea that I'm here they
can't crawl in here right good
looking at your body hey you're looking
good lady alrighty then you can kill one
of them but it'd be better if I could
just get past them both I'm assuming
that I got to get over there I really
don't know if I'm taking this way slower
than I need to but I want it okay that
door did open up okay
turn down that path go forward take a
step forward
don't moonwalk come on stop dancing why
in there that's that's where I want go
oh go on here I totally forgot about
this okay so that means the he's right
there oh now you're gonna go that
direction
oh now you cooperate with me well with
your sass mr. good spot of blood here
that's where the thing got his head
caved in by my heel all right okay we
made it I could have done that wafer I
could have just run for that oh man
but it would have been it wouldn't have
been as tactically advantageous to do
that okay let's see anything here no
it's fine okay so now I can get to the
hand print scanner I should be able to
move forward these that is my assumption
and then I'm gonna find where the hell I
am in relation to everyone else in this
story
okay this is where I let my guard down
and everything is a-okay
nothing bad is gonna happen good thing
they're not letting them go in there
okay yes all right I probably could have
done all that in like five minutes but
me being a coward I don't want to be
patient that sounds terrible great yeah
so I'm gonna wait with this kitty here
and save right now okay
done and done okay got my lap kitty you
get one pet and that's it I'm going get
out of here
yeah yeah yes good animal with yourself
at least he's still alive kishi whatever
gender that cat may be that's a creepy
painting
I'm still wondering like the symbolism
of the first game was very heavy-handed
with like me you know the the barbed
wire stretching around people's faces in
the spike going into the brain of a good
Ruben was quite obsessed with revenge
even something
we discovered what I was doing torture
pinching for traps a serial killer
masquerading around business huh right
okay so maybe that had something to do
with it like the symbolism was in that
regard like it was it was specifically
Ruben and this entire game is centered
around this very visceral very gritty
very brutal art style of design and
that's all because Ruben was totally
insane and really wanted to murder some
people in the most horrific ways and and
maybe that's just like what it's all
about who knows these things I'm trying
my best to look around for any secrets
but I actually don't come on I don't
have my flashlight anymore so I don't
know if I've like permanently lost my
flashlight what does that mean thank you
for making me wait oh these are all the
gritty gross test subjects you want a
that's like no you're covered in glass
you say how about you sir Punk I'll
light up your mind did you two get along
uh-huh that guy doesn't seem too happy
about it okay moving on let me see like
get this one from down town baby
oh come on more oh come on I can do this
I believe in myself damn it I'm gonna
get this yeah it's like throwing the
bread for my first amnesia play through
it
all right fine whatever I'll move on
his demeanor has turned far too
aggressive in his techniques even more
perverse hmm
da Vinci would dissect corpses to
further his anatomical studies but what
Reuben has done goes beyond demanding
his subjects be aware as he dissect them
to truly see how the mind reacts he's
more of a butcher than an artist but we
must remain scientists above all I had
taught him from a young age that the end
shall justify the means but I could not
have predicted things to be this extreme
yeah
Mobius has learned of his involvement
due to my carelessness
I've asked they bring him on board to
assist in development perhaps offering
him better facilities and support will
refocus him and stave off his gruesome
proclivities yeah that's how it works
mass murder is better when you give them
more tools with which to murder masley
all right so anyways for me people like
you you took my life away you turned me
into an abomination finally with this
machine I can go back I can live the
life I was supposed to have we are
forgiving we are willing to overlook
your certain peculiarities for what you
can provide us but you are testing our
limits our manpower our resources are
not here for your pathetic fantasy you
will reverse the calibration on the
machines so we can use it without you
and what if I say no
you think he menace can fix this you
need me and there's no way around it
Rubick no Ruben
this was where he was doing his research
with us we were just using him and I
doubt he's the first yep
in fact I would believe that you're part
of this Wow
I distinctly remember saying way back
when that I was wondering when the walls
were gonna be covered with meat and Ray
the day has come
okay find out what's gonna anyway what I
was gonna say is that the symbolism is
actually represented by the drawings of
the machines like it's all part of it
his gruesome tactics are being used
right now why hello did I hear the
sounds of joy in here oh it's good and
by good I mean now okay all right all
right so we're gonna dive into this in
the next episode so thank you everybody
so much for watching I am glad that the
consequence is in the same vein as the
assignment no weapons all scares thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see